alors gall président qui est en
déplacement à marseille de mercredi à
vendredi
si vous en pensez la raison de manuel
makonda la marseille on a toujours
raison enfin président il a vocation à
aller partout en france le président
maintenant ce que je comprends pas le
président quand je me rends le camembert
le jeu n'aura
non non c'est vous y pensez quand je me
rase seulement non je déconne vous y
pensez vous pas jean messi a dit la
vérité ici on dit tout qui n'a pas qui
n'a pas un jour penser à être président
président du club de bandol
voilà j'en ai souvent pensé vous y
pensez à ça c'est
emmanuel macron vous appelle un jour à
gourbit j'ai pas dis pas prévu tout je
me chauffe et si magna va écouter la
première fois quelqu'un va vous chauffer
si emmanuel macron vous appelle et vous
dit j'aimerais que vous soyez ministre
de l'intérieur est ce que vous y allez
si c'est pour appliquer sa politique
certainement pas donc il m'appellera pas
non mais on s'y dit voilà je vous laisse
les mains libres
mal alors exactement comme je veux faire
oui a donc d'y aller bah oui ah oui et
premier ministre n'avait on est en
mesure non parce que la premier ministre
et celui qui conduit la politique de la
politique doublée de la politique du
gouvernement et qui met en musique la
bouillie la politique sur laquelle
emmanuel mois et déjà hier pour vous
envoyer loin
comme je suis aujourd'hui déjà loin j'ai
pas besoin d'accepter le poste de
ministre du coup un mais c'est vrai que
vous avez déjà pensé vous avez déjà
rencontré le président non j'avais vous
lui diriez quoi s'il était bon ben je
lui a dit me bernard montiel pas lui
dire je lui dirai que c'est c'est
dommage que la france ait perdu un
quinquennat pour rien aulas
qu'est ce que vous lui répondriez ben
voilà aucun intérêt alors franchement
c'est le président répondre et sa non à
ce que répondrez le président je ne sais
pas allé tellement moi je pense qu elle
un peu plus intelligent
la machine estimé par bernard montiel
pour répondre sur le marseille je me
posais vous me posez la question ce que
je comprends pas si vous laissez que le
présent de la glisse se déplace dans une
ville de france pendant trois jours en
général c'est la durée officielle d'un
voyage à l'étranger et ce à trois jours
alors je veux bien que marseille soit
tellement concept le président de la
république s'est déplacé l'ams si
mais pas trop jouer il doit non
seulement il va évidemment seulement il
part 3 juin il a avec sept ministres
mais on dirait qu'ils pardon avec une
délégation dans un pays étranger
concerné invraisemblable